abdelmadjid tebboune kaïs ier d'une
rencontre officielle de deux jours à
tunis l'occasion pour les deux pays amis
et voisins de parfaire leur relation à
l'issue d'une conférence de presse
conjointe donnée hier au palais de
carthage 27 accords ont été signés entre
les deux parties notamment en matière de
justice d'emploi de sécurité et
d'information le point avec notre
correspondant à tunis bassim chez vie
c'est un accueil à la hauteur de
l'engagement de l'algérie qui a été
réservé hier abdelmadjid tabun par son
homologue taïs ayedh pour cette première
visite d'état du président algérien en
tunisie accompagné d'une importante
délégation ministérielle
ce dernier a rappelé dès son arrivée à
l'aéroport présidentielle de tunis
l'importance des liens historiques et
stratégies qui unissent les deux pays à
l'issue d'une conférence de presse
donnée conjointement en palais de
carthage 27 accords de coopération ont
été signés entre les deux parties des
accords portant sur les domaines de la
justice des médias de l'industrie de
l'énergie de la santé ou encore du
commerce extérieur pour rappel les deux
pays sont liés depuis 2008 par un accord
préférentiel ayant permis d'augmenter
notablement le volume des échanges
commerciaux écouter cailly sayyed
nous avons abordé les points communs
ayant réuni nos deux peuples et leur
lutte commune pour la libération
nationale
jamais charbel nous avons également
abordé les mécanismes à trouver
shabana loi pour réaliser le rêve du
peuple uni des deux pays
en marge de cette visite d'état un
accord de prêt d'un montant de 300
millions de dollars a été signé le 9
décembre dernier pour aider le voisin
tunisien en pleine crise économique et
politique à boucler son budget 2021
au-delà de la coopération bilatérale le
prochain sommet de la ligue arabe prévu
en mars prochain à alger a été également
au centre des entretiens entre les deux
alliés au même titre que le dossier
libyen sur lequel les deux présidents
ont une vision commune et convergente
écouter abdelmadjid à bonne date
nous avons discuté des questions
régionales et des problèmes actuels et
échanger les points de vue sur des
questions d'intérêt commun s'agissant
notamment de la situation en libye
je suis d'accord avec le président ça y
est tu pour dire que la solution en
libye doit être un terreau libyenne
elle avait réveillé une
visite qui sonne comme une bouffée d'air
frais pour le pays du jasmin enfoncé
dans une crise politique économique et
sociale sans précédent accentuée par le
coup de force du président sayed du 25
juillet dernier